[Music]
does your organization consist of
on-prem pki services but needs to move
to the cloud while maintaining a zero
trust policy with certificate
authorities
organizations use private certificate
authorities cas to create and manage
their certificates across the
organization
these certificates are used to
authenticate machines and services such
as computers devices and microservices
many enterprises rely on on-premise pki
services which typically have a root ca
and a subordinate ca for certificate
issuance
but what do you do when you're migrating
a part or the whole of your organization
to the cloud and you need to maintain
zero trust principles for secure
communication with your cas
that's where a certificate authority
service cas comes in
cas provides fully managed cloud native
cas for gcp customers and in conjunction
with vpc service controls provides a new
approach to cloud native security
while on-premise root cas are frequently
kept offline google cloud uses layered
controls to ensure that access to cas is
protected by context-aware access
control
let's dig into how these controls work
to maintain zero trust
security administrators can use virtual
private cloud or vpc service controls to
create a security perimeter around
sensitive data stored in google cloud
platform resources when the perimeter is
enforced resources can easily share data
within the perimeter boundary as long as
iam and vpc firewall policies allow it
any access from the outside on the other
hand is restricted by default
these default constraints protect
resources from
large-scale data exfiltration
decrease the risk of data leakage
mitigate iam misconfigurations protect
from risk of lost or stolen credentials
and compromised applications from
transferring data outside of the ingress
egress and context-aware rules
speaking of rules there are four
controls to allow access to and from a
perimeter
perimeter bridges which enable
communication to services and share data
across service perimeters
ingress rules which determine who has
access from outside the perimeter into
it
egress rules that determine who has
access from inside the perimeter to the
outside and access levels which permit
access to resources based on contextual
information about the request
for example you might create an access
level called high level that will permit
requests from a small group of highly
privileged individuals
all of these access configuration
elements are connected to access content
manager acm for short which allows
google cloud organization managers to
build fine-grained attribute-based
access controls for google cloud
projects and resources
these policies are based on user
identity device health and other
contextual criteria here you can see
certificate authority service cas inside
of vpc's service controls perimeter
the service resides in its own project
denoted as app project there are four
access points to cas
one cas admin needs to access the
services from the internet using access
content manager or acm
acm uses endpoint verification to gather
information regarding user devices
including operating system and version
thus access to cas is based on the
context of their request and not only on
admin credentials
two services and principles within the
parameter can access cas service based
solely on iam permissions
three
vpc service controls ingress and egress
rules that specify the direction of
allowed access to and from different
identities and resources
the rules also support granular access
control such as the requested api
project ip address and allowed methods
and four if only part of your org is on
the cloud and you need on-prem access to
cas this is facilitated by providing
service account keys to the compute
engine on-prem or by leveraging workload
identity federation for a short-lived
access token
alternatively the perimeter can be
extended to the on-prem network using a
vpn or interconnect
security access controls rely on
service-based identity centralized
enforcement policy security requirements
applied consistently to all services and
a centralized view of security as you
can see all of these controls come
together to fiercely protect the ca and
certificates being issued from it while
on the cloud
so you get the ability to access cloud
resources and services while maintaining
access on-prem for as long as you need
check out the links in the description
for resources i've mentioned during the
video and if you've enjoyed this please
give it a thumbs up and make sure to
subscribe so that you never miss the
great content that we put out weekly
have any questions leave them in the
comments see you on the next episode of
certificate authority service thanks for
watching
[Music]
you